i think we all know who it's about
rhymes with hake billenhall let's serve
up some news sunny side up
huffpost is reporting that oprah's
singing really stole the show it's this
post that oprah put up herself and the
clip has gone viral it's oprah singing
along so hard and maybe not knowing all
the words have you ever been to karaoke
with oprah she she's not a karaoke girl
i'm telling you can you imagine
it's not it's honest to god it's not her
but you guys have taken road trips yes
we are so who's
the roach that's a really good point to
to the point that nate is making we've
done road trips she can ride in the car
who does this with no music
i can't no music she prefers to ride in
the car as she said to me to be alone
with her thoughts i go but you're not
alone i'm sitting
here let me dive into this
and i know you love to sing and you know
i can't sing that i know you can't
that's where you're going so do you
think maybe oprah said that because she
don't like you'll see
no any chance
the boston globe reports that she just
released her re-recorded
red album and it's stacked it's got 30
tracks clocking in at over two hours of
music
and then she hit us with a 10-minute
performance of all too well on snl this
weekend
and released not one but two new videos
one directed by tayte herself and the
other by friend and collaborator blake
lively ross not only would taylor what
is she gonna do next but do we think she
sleeps i know right so this is what
taylor did during the pandemic girl take
a day off
do you feel like right we're lazy
compared to her and
that 10-minute song all too well so this
was the song that was going to be about
can we go there rumored well i think we
all know who it's about
rhymes with hake billenhall yes
so i woke up sunday morning and trending
on twitter was jake gyllenhaal and of
course i clicked to see why imagine if
you were him though it's just another
sunday good morning
insider reports meghan markle has one
suggestion
she thinks that instagram should add a
dislike button she says it would allow
people to show they disagree without
having to pile on more and more negative
comments
she and harry famously quit social media
after all the toxic messages harry
recently cited one interesting report
that found 70 percent of the hate speech
aimed at megan came from just 50
accounts really
it's you know what this made me realize
also is
um
if i was to try and find some positive
aspect of this that i thought that maybe
instead of everybody going bananas and
being mean to each other maybe these
smaller sources are just getting blown
up out of proportion and seeming like
the bigger picture when if you get down
to the root of the root and the bud of
the bud maybe it's a little more narrow
and not so widespread the negativity so
i thought
as much as uh this was so illuminating
um
maybe it goes to show that there is not
as much vitriol out on the planet maybe
it's coming from smaller sources and
sort of you know getting blown out of
proportion like it's a small negative
minority who's just real loud i think
that's what my naive optimistic you know
happy positive person wants to believe
but that is a fascinating stat i would
have not guessed that no well i want to
quote the great taylor swift hater's
going to hate hate hate hate
no matter what you do
the thing
about a dislike button is it to me it
feels like a welcome mat for negativity
it's you know it's too many options like
like or just like
people are negative enough online you
know what i'd rather have than a dislike
button a big old block button because if
you come at me and you're negative peace
out goodbye
yes you can block people yeah but it's
like a three-step process they're like
are you sure you want to block them have
you thought about it are you really sure
girl i'm sure
timeout reports that the streaming
service has purchased the bay theater in
pacific palisades it's a legendary
theater that closed over the pandemic
but netflix is opening at backup to
feature films in the netflix library
like their new western the harder they
fall and adam mckays don't look up but
what i want to know is
and this is important what are they
going to charge for popcorn oh this is
this gets you going i just went to the
movie theater with my daughters and
their two friends because they were
having a sleepover okay so it's four
four kids four kids and two adults two
adults we bought stuff at the concession
stand it was 170
and i sat there with my jaw on the floor
and i just thought
i feel very privileged to have the means
to say i can afford this right now and i
have every bone in my body saying this
is unacceptable but they charge that at
the concession stands because they have
to pay their rent they're not doing it
to us they're trying to stay open
themselves and i understand that and i
empathize i just want to find out a way
that we don't have to charge people
those kinds of prices to take their
families to the theater
the new york times reports hot singles
is a weekly email newsletter that drops
a new hottie in your inbox every week
it's put together by rhonda sakala and
you can subscribe for free you'll meet
eligible singles like plant-based
princess looking for a romaine tick
partner yes you did
let us applaud for this city bike boy
looking for a city bike bay to take him
for a ride
okay each ad includes a photo and a q a
to get to know your hottie a little
better it's funny because hot singles
gives me like sort of young trendy like
sexy vibes and i feel like this is a
little bit more
old world a little more patient a little
more thoughtful this is not the boom
yeah so hot singles like the name
doesn't kind of measure up to the sort
of old worldness of being patient
waiting weekly responding in a letter
personal ads yeah can i ask you some
questions that you could answer in this
hot singles ad sure okay um what are you
looking for in a partner
someone who can be nice every day
oh that's good
and i wish these things for everybody
yeah you know i have to say if i wasn't
engaged and you know if straight
straight
i mean those are a couple big hurdles
but we could have really get it off
really something could have happened
here
before we say goodbye i want to share
something with you from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to things that i really love that i want
to share with you because i think you
might enjoy them and we wanted to share
a snippet of a holiday movie that we're
really excited about starring our friend
michael yeary it's called single all the
way how has that title not been used and
it comes out on netflix december 3rd and
it's actually the first gay holiday
rom-com on netflix we make this show for
you
so take it with you
[Music]